[Music]
[Applause]
that is an exclusive look at 16 year old
Mariah for Micah's crazy performance on
the voice tonight she gets all four
judges to turn around she has a lot of
heart oh yeah and you know whoever gets
her is gonna have the edge and you know
Blake probably has a good shot cuz he
always does and speaking of Blake well
only easy online so official Lacey was
with him they got his reactor to his
buddy Luke Bryan joining Idol and also
got him to talk about his growing
relationship with Gwen I heard you
soundchecking earlier I heard Gwen with
you oh yeah they're dead it's gotta be
nice I see you guys come down here all
the time with the boys we have so much
fun I don't think you should be able to
have that much fun it's probably not
legal in California they've been
together nearly two years but what was
it like when the two first fell in love
we were just
when joint Blake had a concert
celebrating his new restaurant and bar
all red Tishomingo in Oklahoma that's
his baby right now but could he and Gwen
have any productions of their own in the
future you see yourself having more kids
I mean the kids clearly adore you you're
putting them in music videos that sparks
like a paternal instinct in you I don't
know I think the voice sparked that in
me if anything it's good early on and
I've just kind of rolled with it and as
for Luke Bryan joining Idol well it
seems Blake had a big hand in that I'm
sure the the executives at ABC are
really pissed at me right now for for
what they probably had to pay him to get
him on that show but good for you Luke
stick it to him Luke Bryan it's not
cheap yeah he looks it but he's not true
boys always having so much fun right all
right ed just to make it clear we spoke
with Blake Shelton before the tragedy
and Las Vegas and although the voice was
pre-taped they have added a message to
the show that will acknowledge the
tragedy tonight
[Music]
you